[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de france 24 empezamos a este
programa en la capital chilena santiago
donde el arte callejero quiere
transformar lugares que fueron
protagonistas de las revueltas sociales
para resignificar los y generar una
nueva energía las obras de la edición
2022 del festival abrió fronteras
invitan además a reflexionar sobre la
migración y la naturaleza nuestra
corresponsal patricia luna nos cuenta
más
el estudio creativo lira arte pionero en
chile en el arte callejero encargó a la
muralista chilena anís cambiar la
energía de uno de los espacios donde se
acumuló en la radio de las
manifestaciones desde la revuelta social
de 2019 y el 8 en la rebautizada como la
plaza de todas
diferentes como personas que están
mujeres que están ocultas tras las
flores
en verdad la solución a eso tiene que
ver las que ya no están porque las que
están desapareciendo y las que aparecen
también con la luz o sea cuando ya hay
un juego
de presencia de ausencia utilizando como
inspiración el poema sobre lanzar de
forma conjunta de la escritora gabriela
mistral con bailarinas que se dirigen
hacia el altar anís recrea un espacio
que abarca lugares distintos como la
plaza y la salida del método una
solución a esas personas que ya no están
esas mujeres tuvieron a estar entonces
también por eso se dice generar y sobre
todo cómo era este lugar como un espacio
más sagrado como un espacio que tiene
como un ánimo mucho más
cómo decirlo como de memoria d
de reconocimiento un altar con velas
ánforas simbología sagrada las latinas y
también semillas que marcan una nueva
vida oscurece y muy cerca de allí anís
explica a los interesados otra de sus
obras uno de los cuatro murales del
festival abrir fronteras de santiago
intervenida lumínicamente con la llegada
de la noche que retrata a una mujer con
una fuerte presencia de la naturaleza el
festival es una invitación a reflexionar
sobre la inmigración representa una
mujer pueden tener muchas mujeres en
distintos lugares del mundo
el mundo
de las crisis climáticas ambientales
políticas
es crisis de desplazamiento que viven
especialmente las mujeres de américa
latina la obra de anís encarna en esta
mujer haitiana o centroamericana el
rostro que personifica a la que podría
ser cualquiera de nosotras
de chile a benin a las ciudades se
transforman en lienzos para contar
historias en contó en un 26 grafiteros
locales e internacionales crearon un
mural que se extiende por más de un
kilómetro son obras que rinden homenaje
a la cultura beninesa y que busca
reconectar al país con su pasado para
pintar el nuevo vino se pueden encontrar
por ejemplo representaciones de los
tesoros devueltos por francia en
noviembre
esta verdad
en francia justamente otra pintura causa
sensación el san jerónimo de leonardo da
vinci una obra maestra que el genio
toscano nunca acabó es un préstamo
excepcional de los museos del vaticano
para el castillo del club y el lugar
donde da vinci pasó los tres últimos
años de su vida un cuadro que los
visitantes podrán descubrir hasta el 20
de septiembre
y del lado de sería la ciudad de la de
llevar un tesoro patrimonial del siglo
11 está recuperando poco a poco su
condición de destino turístico en este
país devastado por la guerra entre 2012
y 2017 el grupo terrorista estado
islámico utilizaba el sitio para lanzar
ataques y entrenar a niños soldados hoy
gracias al aumento de la seguridad los
visitantes están regresando
volvemos a américa latina para hablar de
los intercambios musicales del álbum
atlantic estéreo un proyecto que reúne a
artistas franceses y colombianos
26 grandes nombres de la escena
electrónica colaboraron para ofrecer 12
temas y entre ellos flor con motivo del
lanzamiento la yiyi francesa vino a
bogotá la capital colombiana para tocar
en shows y participar en un taller con
los niños del barrio popular de ciudad
bolívar como parte del proyecto del dj
colombiano julio victoria que busca
democratizar las herramientas de la
música electrónica
escuchamos a flor
bastantes talleres generalmente para
adultos
pero creo que siempre es divertido hacer
que los niños descubran estas vidas y
esta música
[Aplausos]
sobre todo ahora que la música
electrónica empieza a estar en todas
partes y a mezclarse con muchas culturas
fuera de europa y eeuu
así que creo que hay muchas cosas muy
interesantes que pueden surgir de este
tipo de momentos especialmente con los
niveles
[Música]
y es con otro dije que seremos este
programa disney el francés más escuchado
del mundo estrenó una nueva canción que
mezcla sonidos electrónicos y era ray a
un popular estilo musical de argelia el
país de su madre nos despedimos entonces
con el ritmo hipnótico de disco magreb y
su impresionante videoclip dirigido por
el jazz ver cada idioma gafas gracias
por su confianza y cuídense
[Música]
[Aplausos]